- So you have a ton of quick changes.
People try and get me to do this thing,
and (laughs) I, I-
- It's exhausting.
And I'm like, I'm running back there
and I'm like, I, do you ever miss,
have you ever missed, one, a quick change,
or have you ever like just come out
and been like, "Well it
wasn't all put together"?
- Yeah, "I didn't quite make it."
No, you know what?
I think that would be
such a fun game to do.
- Oh.
- You should-
- That should be a game on this show.
- You could do a quick-change challenge.
No, I'm just-
- Quick Change Challenge is
our next game on this show.
(laughs)
- I know, I know.
But it was like, okay, I want the audience
to try out a quick change challenge,
see how quickly you can get out
and back in to another set of clothes.
I'm telling you, it is-
- It's thought out, yeah.
Well, I've hosted the Billboard Awards,
so that's the only time
I've done quick changes
that are like, yeah, they're, it's like
less than three minutes
sometimes or two minutes
and it's like super quick
and it's like, I don't know-
- Something breaks.
- Something breaks, you go
out there like, "Just pin it!"
- Yeah, no, exactly.
There's lots of swearing
in the quick change.
- Yes, 100%, no, we're really classy.
That never happens.
- It's a scream.
Swear fast, you have to
get out there in time.
- So you've never come out
on stage and just completely,
cuz one time in my quick
change they forgot to-
- Zip you up?
- Do something.
They zipped me but didn't do the,
and I jumped around a lot on that tour
and so my dress almost
came completely off.
And I was commando (laughs)
(audience laughs)
so that that would've gone
real European beach real quick.
- Yeah, holy.
- Caught it, I caught it.
Has anything ever
happened to you like that?
- I've had things like that
happen, I've had other,
I think the biggest
mishap I've had on stage,
well, actually, the biggest mishap
I've had on stage was my horse.
- Oh no.
- One time, yeah.
My horse, I was on
stage, drops a big poop.
(Kelly laughs)
And I mean, it's big and it's steamy
and it's stinky, you know?
I mean, not for me, I love
the smell of horse poop.
(Kelly laughs)
Everything I own smells
like horse poop, but.
But it was just really awkward, you know?
And so I just had to say,
"Well, (beep) happens."
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- I actually would've loved that,
being at that show, oh my gosh.